noël pour ses enfants n'est qu'un jour
de vacances comme les autres un jour où
l'on s'amuse à faire de longues
glissades sur les toboggans de boisés de
glace construit chaque hiver dans tous
les parcs de la ville
le père noël a fini sa tournée depuis
longtemps c'est au soir du nouvel an
qu'en russie la distribuer ses cadeaux
au carrefour de l'europe et de l'asie
toutes les superstitions s'enchevêtrent
les russes suivent ainsi le calendrier
chinois qui veut que l'année du cochon
cède la place à celle du rat pour ces
orthodoxe privé pendant des décennies de
la liberté de pratiquer ouvertement leur
culte
noël est avant tout une fête religieuse
à la petite église de la rue du
télégraphe au centre de moscou
les premiers fidèles arrive bien avant
la messe de minuit
lévesque au fil des dix dernières années
a vu son église se remplir plus à vous
cela s'est plutôt rester de quoi qui est
profonde
bon d'accord chacun les peuples sont
profondément consciente
ans
la mesure à deux heures qu'on tue et de
chants et de prières
e
en ces temps difficiles alors que le
pays est plongé en pleine crise
économique
beaucoup viennent ici chercher un
réconfort implorer une grâce
la célébration de noël est une fête qui
renaît et de plus en plus de non
croyants des années viennent à l'église
à cette occasion ce rythme la vie est
tellement dure 17 femmes ce que pour ne
pas être tenté par le mal il faut croire
au bien espérer sa victoire et enseigner
cela nos en fourchette les plus pauvres
sont restés à la porte
en ce jour de noël eux espèrent profiter
au passage des voeux de charité des
fidèles de l'église